team tonight from the field only 10
points
Joe what do you think is next for this
team after a season like this and Taylor
was in here talking about
you Dez and Jaron really leading this
team through the off season I guess when
you look ahead what do you see
um I feel like it starts with us you
know pretty much getting healthy and you
know that's the number one thing for us
um secondly no just getting back to work
um pretty much feel like you know it's
that simple
you feel like a healthy team could have
done more 100 percent
why what's up
I mean you know you have Stevo coming
back which you know a problem this
series was rebounded and you know before
he went out he was
pretty much the best rebounder in the
league
um you know obviously BC with you know
what he bringing for us off the bench
you know that's another big body you
know we have out there and somebody you
know who helps us you know on the boards
and scoring wise Luke spacing the floor
you know being able to shoot
um even you know with me
um you know I was out there battling but
I wasn't you know 100 so
um obviously you know health is
important
um we play with what we got so you know
not even trying to you know use that you
know as an excuse right now
um but no even with you know the guys we
had you know we got to be better
and for how competitive the team was the
past two games what do you how do you
account for how quickly this one got
away from you
um I felt like even though you know it
got away early I feel like you know we
were still bottling
um for the most part you know they you
know started knocking down some shots I
feel like you know they was you know
pretty much just getting to the paint
too easy
um for us and
um that would you know pretty much hurt
us you know in recent games it wasn't
you know as easy for them you know we
were making them work
um you know forcing tough shots and you
know that pretty much allowed us to you
know rebound and run
um obviously you know our bigs tonight
was in foul trouble
um which we lacked you know pretty much
right now you know with due to injuries
um
yeah I just feel like it was that you
know we just got to be you know more
locked in on the defensive end and you
know keep guys in front and if you're a
man to get beat you know how your
brother's about
John you know the I'm fine in the west
comments going to get thrown back in
your face at this point yeah I don't
mind I don't care I said it you know I
deal with it so and the other thing I
want to ask you how do you evaluate
yourself as the leader of this team this
year and how do you think you can grow
in that area uh just got to be better
you know with my decision making
um that's pretty much it you know off
the court issues you know
um affected us as you know uh
organization
um pretty much so yeah just more
discipline
kind of along those lines but it's
something we've been talking to
everybody else about there's been some
themes about taking things for granted
not enjoying every moment you know maybe
even a little entitlement for for the
team how do you see that those issues
and if they've related to this team my
issue no do you feel like your team at
large
took things for granted this year that
you hadn't taken for granted in the past
no
okay Dez and Taylor had talked about
they thought that that was the case that
maybe
um you know last year everybody was a
little more locked into the to the
moment and this year that just some
things were expected and
you know people have different opinions
okay
okay I don't know what you want me to
say like you asked me
I said no you know they felt like that
then
you know that's you know their opinions
but um
I mean
you know we here definitely got to be
better though so
um
logged in is you know a key in the
playoffs
so I don't know if you saw what Jana
said the other night about learning from
experience yeah I want to be that big of
a deal like he was so I just wanted to
know what you're taking out of the sun
total of this year and if each year in
the NBA is a
step what did you take from this step
um you know like how you know recently
just said before I feel like you know
mine is
uh more you know off the court end on on
the court you know
um
just
being disciplined on both sides you know
off the court you know making better
decisions you know on the court
um you know
being locked in you know even more
being you know a leader of this team you
know it pretty much you know start with
me so you know however you know I attack
you know any situation you know I know
you know my guys will follow so you know
I just got to be better you know in that
area